body sister at home we got together for work we
shot I didn’t hear wandering for sure I
heard buying neither a whistle nor a rustle we
didn’t hear a lot gave a stupid we didn’t
even understand it was the last apartment
with no apartment no shoes windows and the doors
took out by themselves these doors were
closed
by this
shell hit the apartment is completely
destroyed in the hall, I will live then
I will cut the communication sign and no further
bolts and who will help me
but fell fell the apartment did not remain itself
barely alive
until if it was already alive and
would probably live no longer
from the frame flew into the barn  went away like a rocket
again I don’t know I just why the projectile is
so I just why would I live here the
school handrail right up to us cheap was visible and I
just came choke
dota for the fight